No my dog my parents specifically can't
live with my brother not because of my
brother's habit so much it's because my
parents still till this day try to baby
my own brother and it's [ __ ] annoying
to watch when I was in Sacramento I had
the flu I was dying I was I felt with
like a fever of like a hundred and
something shimmering my ass off and I
was getting annoyed because I could hear
my dad just nagging my brother on the
other side and so when I on the third
day when I was feeling better I still
had a fever and body chills my dad was
like telling me he goes like dude your
brother he's being so difficult I don't
understand why he does his stuff and I
literally told my dad [ __ ] leave him
alone as I'm dying from the fever yeah
what do you mean I'm like I can hear
through the door
how annoying you're being he was like
well I don't like the way that he
responds to me I'll say let me ask you
something
he is 35 right he's 35 years old
how annoying is it that every time my
brother makes a cough sneeze sniffle
fart yeah you act you ask if he needs to
go to the hospital
he literally does this my brother would
burp right but he goes you have in the
shed indigestion
do you need medicine do you go to the
hospital dance 35 years old my brother
gets up from the seat he goes why he's
our you go in the bathroom why does your
stomach hurt
what's wrong damn he's panicked yeah and
my my brother's like dude [ __ ] leave
me alone shut the [ __ ] up I'm 35 like
let me know and he's been doing that to
my brother since day one since he was a
child exactly he's been baby him since
why was he a fragile baby I don't know
but my mom told me too that you know
that's like what every parent says that
I never did that for you because I knew
you were strong I was like or you just
hated my guts
but like but my dad never he he always
my mom and dad always babied him that
way and you know he's a grown-ass man
but it still hasn't stopped so it gets
really [ __ ] annoying sometimes when
it's just like you know I'm just trying
to chill out let me breathe for a second
like but he farted and my bad my bad my
dad was like you have indigestion and
you go to the hospital he farted as if
he's never farted before in his life
that's [ __ ] funny yeah and I'm over
here with the fever didn't check on me
once why
like [ __ ] this guy man but yeah my
brother was just like dude if you didn't
come to Sacramento for the holidays I I
would have I would have [ __ ] loaded
for some like traumatic past event like
your brother was like sick and he almost
died as a child or whatever that means
telling you guys and they're just
[ __ ] paranoid I think they just think
they don't know that my brother's a lot
more capable than he seems because I
think their level of comparison is like
me that the problematic kid who did
things his own way and you know things
turned out pretty well for him and so my
brother was somebody who I think my
older brother is a very smart guy very
intelligent very empathetic he has a lot
of great qualities that I don't have but
the one thing that he does have as a
flaw is that sometimes he lets the world
beat him up and he stays down hmm
he's not really used to a lot of
adversity and I think us a lot a lot of
great things happened to him and it just
came to him without him having to work
hard because it's because maybe your
parents kept rescuing my parents kept
rescuing them he was always he was
always more book-smart than I was very
nice guy good-looking dude and so when
he's faced with adversity sometimes he
doesn't have that ability to really
fight for it because my parents never
let him [ __ ] fight for it oh right
her just like oh my god we got to take
him to the hospital you farted exactly
and so it may also get upset at him
sometimes when he's not capable of doing
these things but it's like that's your
fault and then they destroy his
confidence yeah you handicapped him yeah
like that's not his fault like you and I
told my dad too recently I was like how
come you can't take responsibility
that's some of the qualities that you
don't like in my older brother your son
is also actually do because of the way
that you raised him you got and except
that is stubborn ox yeah it's like you
got to accept that like you babied him
he's sometimes the stuff that you see
him that you don't like it's also
because of the way that you treated him
as an adult and as a kid like it's hard
for him to really understand that
because in this man he goes I did the
best that I could
I understand effort doesn't mean what
the result was though exactly he's all
like trying to defend himself man he's
kind of a kid yeah you know and a lot of
the qualities that my dad doesn't like
about him my brother is the stuff that
he has it's like those are your
qualities actually dude and my brother
fighting on is about his own
insecurities actually a hundred per size
that your brother is triggering
[ __ ] that he doesn't like about himself
mm-hmm that's whoa my dad and my brother
sometimes they clash horns a lot because
they they're actually very very similar
they're both very shy human beings
they're very reserved
they kind of like bottle up their
emotions a lot and so they might my dad
sees that as a weakness because he sees
that in himself as well there's a lot of
things that he saw that my dad might my
his dad my grandpa [ __ ] up on is a
stuff that I used to get my ass beat for
because he saw the the terrible
qualities at my grandpa had and he saw
it in my behaviors hmm and so he used to
get [ __ ] mad at me like for example
like my my grandpa just wasn't very
knowledgeable about a lot of things so
he put his fate in the hands of other
people around him and because he did
that I used to own this Tupperware a
business this upper row company where
they would make Tupperware lids and like
whatever what not very successful my dad
grew up with a lot of money when he was
super younger in Korea in Korea but he
trusted his money to other people they
took all of his money became bankrupt
and so when I didn't know things and I
wasn't knowledgeable about things my dad
would get mad at me he goes like do you
want to be just like your grandpa it's
like wow you're like pushing this [ __ ]
on me
he's like got all these insecurities
that he's just lashing out at for sure
like and I can miss the chill man yeah
man and I think he's had the crazy thing
is he's actually chilled out like 90% so
could you imagine how much worse he was
when I was younger like especially
having a kid like me who wanted who
actually had the qualities that he
somewhat liked to which is me being
persistent but it wasn't persistent in
the stuff that he wanted me to be
persistent in you know what the crazy
thing is though you know we grew up with
a lot of adversity and we went through a
lot of tension with our family but
looking back I'm like I'm here today
doing things that I want because I
fought for it [ __ ]
you know and I'm like well you know
kinda worked I did complain about bad
you know parenting I did complete
complain about um you know the abusive
relationship or whatever but at the end
of the day man it all